it's not even dark people look out their
windows and see this
[Music]
the first train of thought locals are
just completely baffled and can't
squeeze out a word a few moments later
they erupt in sheer fury and they scream
[Music]
their next thought is it even safe to
leave their homes now the hooded thugs
smash blow up and burn mostly cars they
know what they're doing they know how to
do it they are a team in the last few
days there were almost identical scenes
everywhere you see a flame I can Swedish
media say at least about a hundred cars
are now burned out pieces of metal
police have made a number of arrests but
basically the country still in the dark
about who's behind the Menace
is complete
[Music]
neutral hit and about three weeks sweets
will be voting for their new Parliament
well now politicians there have more
things to worry about than stuff like
their election promos the most addictive
the question has to be asked to those
people what the heck were you doing do
you think you are born you destroyed the
whole area for the neighbors for the
children on their way to critical you
have to see burnt-out cars but of course
they must be hard response from society
somewhat strong words but not as
emotional as society which clearly wants
the ones in charge to get it sorted
[Music]
such neighborhood disasters don't come
out of nowhere when it comes to all
kinds of street crime lately
Sweden's been getting less and less safe
one time I was attacked by five people
and they took my wallet bike increased
number of shootings it's gotten worse in
every way policeman said that he had
never experienced anything like it
before he's changed to radically it is
not the Sweden I remember and when years
of ignoring the trends backfired
literally with flames someone the
Swedish elite chose not to talk about
mistakes rather they came up with
conspiracies where in other words
pointed the finger at right-wing
extremists some quote-unquote dark
forces
they want the elections to be about
arsons they want to fuel disgust and
fear I hope the whole thing is not
orchestrated by the dark forces that
threaten our democracy and our
independence last night's events with
one month left before the election were
well organized did not surprise me if
the extreme rights were involved in some
way a false flag by the extreme right
version is popular among some
journalists to Sweden Democrats
sympathizes of running around in the
suburbs burning cars in a coordinated
action to direct criticism and the
suburbs population in the hope of
favoring SD to make sure Sweden can
dodge any Russian efforts to screw up
its election Stockholm has even splashed
out on the media so that they could wipe
out the neverending fake news that was
only to be hit by a wave of homegrown
conspiracies before the police had at
least something solid for the public
alia petrenko RT Swedish police note
that similar attacks have happened in
several Swedish towns in previous years
but on a far smaller scale and we spoke
to Swedish Democratic MP Kent Ekeroth
whose party has sparked controversy over
its anti-immigration stance he says
people are starting to realize that
Sweden is not as safe as they thought
the situation in Sweden I started to
slip out in the international arena when
people suddenly realized whoops Sweden
is not the nice little safe country
thought it was but now realized what the
hell happened to Sweden and so this has
begun for a long time and we have had
major arsons and riots many years back I
just saw some statistics that the arson
attacks in cars with intent has gone up
in 12 to 30 percent and from 967 to 1500
cases a year or something like that so I
mean it's been going up in in actual
numbers too
you